people of Yemen are suffering from the
worst humanitarian crisis in the last
100 years twenty two point two million
people are in need of urgent
humanitarian assistance nearly 100,000
children have already died one Ummah are
on the ground providing food water and
medicine we can only help everybody with
your support my initial reaction was
this this isn't this isn't right really
yeah immediately I was like I mean why
you why are you promoting such people
I'll be honest yeah I used to respect
movement along this journey this road
that I travel on from mature for now
where my clothes had holes in them I'm
after always picking to the night east
maschino and Musashi nice no laces inner
Archie's new millennium picking on
college students young ones little ones
said I won a convent oh he better care
to brothers and sisters and dear friends
yes welcome to another show with smart
agenda now we had a little boy boy boy
boy boy sitting here making statements
or perfunctory yes
picking on untrained ones young ones
untrained ones little ones weak ones
[Laughter]
oh sorry
okay so honey well by the way promise
sisters if you're going through any kind
of depression or anxiety what like I was
watching some stuff yeah yeah
I personally opened that video of a job
and I watch it well I am being it
because psychologically your body
releases certain endorphins endorphins
endorphins yeah but actually you should
force yourself to smile okay so
basically I don't know if you know but
Mufti Meg was doing a life and we know
the last time he did alive and invited a
sister what happened there
we actually did one as well yeah very
good hum doula
but now this time he Adam sorry brother
Abu Saleh and slim joined the life shady
maybe yes you mean maybe like hasn't
enough in there you're going to find out
so now I want ask you a question what
was your first reaction to that okay let
me give you my genuine first reaction to
that we're gonna watch the video but
what was the first reaction when you saw
like Mufti monk gained them on their
live feed and talking in general how did
you feel my initial reaction was this
this isn't this isn't right really yeah
immediately I was like I mean why you
why are you promoting such people that
was my immediate like without logically
or religiously put in stuff emotionally
yeah just an emotional reaction was why
are you promoting them that what that
was my thing like yeah yeah I mean she
I'm sure that there's other people that
would if you promote them they would
actually bring benefit to the people but
hey you're promoting these guys like are
they gonna be they're gonna be bringing
benefit to the people beyond this year I
used to respect most him in Cologne when
he brought Adam Saleh and shades mother
let me Allah bless all three of them
here we have nothing personal against
him I was like really like come on
really now most has been speaking to me
and he said him bro don't be reactionary
and I've made a promise to myself that
any kind of controversy that happened
I'm either gonna stay away from it
oh I'm gonna wait a week or two it's
just the content and let think so
because sometimes we're it's like we get
a rush up oh no I have to do no that's
what took you on board so what I've done
is this was about week ago two weeks ago
another yeah so thinking a lot I've been
thinking yeah why would you do that
yes but then my respect for him grew
further so I used to respect him but now
my respect bruton now you'll be saying
to me oh okay why
clickbait anna well you can't say that
as well but I'm being honest because the
thing is I had to reflect myself and say
Ali yeah where would you seven years ago
eight years ago learning grammar I wish
that these are my concerns where was you
you don't wanna know I said nah you know
I didn't be let's watch it in every
further yeah okay so
I said I'm gonna go I'll be honest we're
not for his reaction I'll be honest bro
as a buffer of my heart melted no cuz I
was like wow like he was really excited
he was really happy like specially the
cilium who was at y'all and you get it
I found this reaction funny I found it
as a buffer to Bravo like it I don't
know how to explain it but it was like
you know when you sometimes you're in a
bad place
yeah and there's someone that you look
up to yeah and you see him because we
get that on the road it sometimes
probably you know that video you did you
changed my life
I felt as if it's like I don't know
seems in every way I'm seeing somebody
humble you know that video yeah you know
I'm selling drugs on the road but I felt
how he felt there so the fingers it was
it was it was refreshing
but let's carry on watchin and there's a
lot of respect to soil for that key you
see the way he's addressing was Mufti
yes aim of teasing hey y'all thank you
exactly so it's nice it's nice house
very well how are you guys do all right
yeah we're doing great we're here in New
York no we love you so much everything
that you do everything we support
[Applause]
[Music]
everything your videos your words it
helps you become like a better person
well us here Dee and I appreciate you so
much and I want to meet you one day
while I really do don't you because and
let's try and reach out to the oume
family by saying a few good words and
here is my shot up you know the duo
themselves ma sha allah may allah bless
you guys and give you goodness what do
you think tell me like what can we do
people we gets into that yeah by the way
guys I am raising I'm trying to raise
twenty thousand pounds for human by the
way so make sure you check the link and
I shall give for the sake of allah
subhanaw taala
but you know I was gonna ask for
question man why do we sometimes feel
like the message of Islam is only
righteous because what he said that he's
like you know who send me a lot bless
you both you know etc you know it's the
message of Islam came to the worst of
the worst people you know the worst of
the worst people and I had to do
self-reflection see you know Ali come on
my where was you before etc you may have
needed someone like that how dare you
think to yourself oh why it's mostly
there etc yes most do you know do you
not feel much demon doesn't know this
but what they do and he does but the
fact that he could reach out to them
[ __ ] maybe he's doing a better job then
we try to do it because we do try to is
what myself and you know above a Musa
and few others we try to help save Yemen
cuz Yemen right now is going through so
much in the media they don't you know
they don't mention anything about Yemen
and we're Yemeni and we're blessed to be
in a platform where we're at right now
and so are you and seeing like I'm
talking to right now is like a dream
you're knowing that we're live and you
can we can help to say something about
helping save Yemen is is amazing
everyone has a different capacity and
everyone deals with things in a
different way we're all very sad as to
what's happening to us is unacceptable
under all circumstances and we as the
Ouma family would like to see a stop to
any form of killing you know the
destruction and so on completely that's
one thing we're all on the same page I
think Mufti make looks like he's
recording this one is microwave I think
you still using dial-up internet yeah I
don't know why sometimes they put me
internet isn't with me maybe it's a deep
fake video like I post a lot every
single day and sometimes you know like
not everyday something that could best
represent me as a person you know like I
make mistakes you know honestly
everything's out there influences and
people keep laconic religious figure but
I always tell them know look at move
team in because like you
like you're more beneficial to the kids
and usually as a more of Islamic figure
like me I'm a normal kid and I mess up a
lot I mess up a lot and that's the thing
is that's the hard part because you're
met your mistakes are out there and in
the young you I want the young kids to
look at my mistakes and as long as they
praise me from my mistakes and stuff so
like I always tell me I'm crazy that
someone maliciously look I'm with you
man because honesty always help me I'm a
better person with serious yeah so it's
important you know one thing with slim
it's it's like the fact that he's
openness in looking I do mistakes yeah I
told him not to look I respect that
because I didn't date he's showing that
he's a human being he makes mistakes
it's actually this stuff that he does
maybe he's not proud of a happy with and
that's genuine and I appreciate that and
he's voicing and saying look I told him
to come watch you see I'm trying to say
is not he's not changing the religion
he's not justifying it he's separating
himself from the same as long as you say
look this is a sin rather then no I can
do I'm trying to say it's so nice to
hear you let me give you good news a lot
of the scholars out there have had some
terrible pasts you know a lot of them
have been worse than anyway you being
too brother slim or brother Adam and I'm
not find you to say that they are bad
today their change their scholars they
probably very impatient for guys like
you but the reason is because I know
their past and I've seen where they were
and now that they're out there
impatience is a sign of their love in a
way for the cause of Allah but they
don't realize sometimes the damage that
happens when you use a bad methodology
to get it cross to people so people who
call you out sometimes you say listen
that's wrong this is wrong consider what
they're paying because if they are right
he should hurt your conscience a little
bit even though you might out of your
own pride defend yourself but at the
same time you must understand that
everyone is different their way of
talking is different they won't show you
so much of love to help you come in they
might hate to help you come in so it's
just leave the guys where they are
letting their peace you popc JAMA and
and the only
as young of mine is every day we should
be better and we were the previous day
that's the main England I want to just
tell you you think nothing Russia I
think that's a very good advice and
giving dower because what he's doing is
he's tailoring his advice based upon
these two individuals and he's giving
them something which is practical he's
not overburdening them and he's not
giving them something that's too too far
ahead or this work towards a saying to
do this now smooth exactly small things
and he's not overburdening them he's
having a conversation I think it's a
very interesting way to kind of learn
how to keep tower well that's important
because that was its yes you have your
general Dawa but you need to sometimes
tailor it mmm sometimes when you speak
to people don't like of Statham's also
says don't give dow word to your
judgment of the atheist that you're
speaking to all atheists are like the
other no prophet might be someone
totally different don't just apply who
you spoke the last week i evil atheist
so ever and applied to he's not the same
atheist he's different tailoring hey
there's another good example they say
knowledge is knowing it sooner to smile
knowledge is knowing it so not to smile
wisdom is not smiling at a Funeral
exactly that's that's fundamental here
and a lot of people have knowledge but
they do not know how to apply that
knowledge I hope someone is screen
recording this so I can know and look
back at the words that you told us
because it's really helping us a lot
always love there's less you might be
look you know I I try to care for
everyone to be honest with you those who
like you those who don't like it it's
fine you know you just know that you're
in love with Allah that's it so if these
are the creatures of Allah let me speak
to them with respect but if they don't
have respect within their own nature
I appreciate it so much I like this bit
now so this bit is where he gives he
gives that that like he's given them you
listen to yourself but hundred it was it
was good I just end off by saying one
one you know one thing if you don't mind
now take you know you know whenever we
have a following whenever we have a
following on social media a lie it's a
responsibility that's based on our
shoulders by Alex think about it because
you know ultimately I'm gonna die you
guys are gonna die we're all gonna die
we would have lived for a very short
period of time when we go we're going
back to Allah and whoever sets a good
example will actually see the reward at
that juncture and whoever didn't will
just regret so whenever we have a
following it's actually a lot love and
he wants to test us to say what are you
gonna do with this following so at least
we try to be responsible in the way we
say things and do things encourage the
younger generation you know what's
happening with the young it's so scary
because so many people in the water so
they don't I mean you're gonna accept my
thank you so much what do you think I
think I think it was neither I was happy
I was happy because I didn't they you
know maybe the thing is if they can take
from
sometimes like maybe I won maybe I will
approaches well maybe I don't know
you're young trying to see even though
we tried to work with never insulted
above others we never like you know we
gave all advice sometimes he was Stern
and like he said we did it because of
our love for them that the thing is bro
what doesn't really get understood is
understanding the variety and the
different types of people who are normal
yeah we're now on social media where
we've got people of different countries
and in different countries you have
different upbringing you have different
customs different different intensities
of the religion being implemented
different trials and online sometimes we
don't get to see that because all
usernames seemed the same all comments
are treated the same but you have to
understand that everyone's going to like
somebody living in America is not going
through the same trials living in India
and that scholarship you can't get
scholarship kind of conflicting because
the person living in America that the
scholar living in America knows was
gonna come or that's why though orlimar
say that he's in a better position to
give up the tower but what's going on
some people came to him and they were
asking for a tower and he said go to
your land and ask the people you know
the scholarism you know because they
knew affairs the best you know and
that's how easier and it comes back to
wisdom because he could have say
something that could go against the
customs of that time Judy I'm trying to
say so that's why it's it's it's very
important inshallah
today that in my balance it says
different cultures you know Muslims are
around the world Judy I'm trying to see
what you may deem as something does you
know like putting your feet on the table
to someone that can be the honest just
normal voice it's not even that it's I
mean think about when somebody is from a
small age when they're learning yeah
their first impression of learning an
alien is what appearance is it yes you
learn from your parents and naturally
parents are going work and a big family
so their harsh there's punishments and
the first impression of the religion is
what our lives watching I don't do this
that's Haram or doing this so from the
small age that's the kind of impression
we have of the religion we go to
religious institutions and over there or
obviously time is show and is a big
pressure so it's or you have to do your
lesson otherwise it's dead there's
detention there's this does that so
Scholarship is always seen as harsh yes
yeah and that's the impression people
now have of scholarship yeah but the
fact of the matter is that that's that
doesn't work with everyone though and
even I think some scholars say as well
that you know even when they try to kind
of crack jokes people thinking oh why is
it YYZ cracking jokes like that's that's
not the right way but that's not the
right way according to how you have
understood the religion especially
people from the subcontinent where
scholars are very kind of stern and
harsh and they have a certain kind of
default position hey our lifestyle is
different
yeah our youth have been brought up in a
different way and this form of Dawa I
think it's important people you cannot
just have and promote and the thing is
people might be saying oh this is not
the way okay
95% of the scholars or let's just say
giving lectures and doing this and doing
that okay that's being done yes what
about for the people that can't relate
to that
shouldn't you be giving them an
alternative if that's what we're happy
that someone like me is out there yeah
because he does genuinely non-muslims
even talk about him so it's amazing and
Hum Dil of we need people on both sides
bro yes new people like most teeming hit
people on the other side you're honest
about the balance Gigi I'm trying to be
balanced they need it but sometimes I
believe we have too much of the
harshness you know and you don't get
many figures that moved him in do people
can relate to soft his smile his gentle
approach etc is also needed and yeah I
was happy like I said before I used to
respect Mufti man here my respect has
gone up for him
because at the end they from ancestors
people need a chance and it was good he
gave them opportunity maybe they will
listen bow maybe all the stuff that
we've done you just require mostly men
to have this little chat for 10 minutes
and it's on the job so I may Allah bless
one of them mashaallah brother Adam
Saleh brother and I mean this I would
love but we're not walking
oh just another joke and Bravo a musty
man and brother smart agenda and the
pusillanimous next time Salaam aleikum
[Laughter]